you know what this collar been named
Oliver would cuz it's a keeper anything
that brings the books to real life I'm
about it totally down super excited
because it's just another way to like
geek out over Harry Potter stuff this is
the kind of dark blue that I would
expect out of Sirius there's a bunch of
different ways I could see this color
leaning this is Raven claw it's blue
dark blue it has to be recline like the
good version of Bellatrix
so that would be serious seriously
serious ooh I like this color it's like
blood it's nicer it's a great to fall
yes oh it looks like I have chocolate
all over my mouth
no someone cast a spell on this right
now this no I don't know I'm not
disagree yep nope the whole heartedly
delete spell do you feel sad or do you
feel evil
I feel evil with this yeah it definitely
reads darker on your lips which is what
I was hoping for for Bellatrix it's very
dark it's very like witchy I can't help
but think I it looks like a mustache
haha
now this without doubt has got to be
Hermione no this has to be Nagini
it's got the shimmer to it so it's got
the like scaling effect this makes me
feel different which i think is part of
being Slytherin in part of Voldemort's
clue
do we even check that we got it yeah
yeah could have made one for each of the
houses mm-hmm you know because yes
there's a Ravenclaw but like I'm all the
puff what am I supposed to wear it makes
me feel like different and I feel like
that's what being a witch and wizard is
all about its being dick changes the way
you think about yourself always my final
thoughts are oughta Cadabra what I said
it deathless forever so does this makeup